I thank everyone in many places and in
different ways who joined in the day
of fasting, prayer and penance that
we experienced last Friday,
imploring peace in the world, let us not
distance ourselves, let us continue to pray for
Ukraine also for the serious
situation evident in
Israel and for the others  regions of the
war
in particular, spaces must be left
to guarantee
humanitarian aid and the hostages must be freed immediately,
and no one abandons the
possibility of stopping the
weapons. Cease the
fire, Father Iim, I
recently listened to him on the
program, his image and Father Ibrahim
said Cease the fire.  Cease fire
he is the vicar of the holy land
we too with father ibraim say cease
fire stop brothers and sisters
war is always a defeat always
always
l